[Music]
[Applause]
jeff darlington is all over the desean
watson story espn nfl reporter kind
enough to join us
jeff let me start with last night the
nfl pa statement that they sent out a
kind of a preemptive strike sort of
challenging the nfl to say hey you guys
have this independent arbitrator we both
agreed on this and we're willing to
accept whatever she you know decides
and it felt like they had to know
something what was your initial thought
when you saw the nfl pa statement
yeah dan one of one of two scenarios
number one maybe they knew something but
number two
the other side of this is that they
obviously recognized that
they agreed to in the collective
bargaining agreement the nflpa agreed
to allow an appeals process that
ultimately gets decided by roger goodell
so of course they want the nfl to say oh
yeah we'll accept what sue robinson says
because ultimately they know that roger
goodell in the case of appeal gets to
make the final decision so in part this
is i think trying to win over the court
of public opinion uh because they fully
know the nfl was not about to give up
that power
you think that the commissioner will
appeal this
i so
i'm not saying i know that look it's a
six-game suspension the nfl proposed a
one-year suspension at the time of the
original hearing with sue robinson uh so
roger goodell has a decision to make
here does he want to respect the process
that includes the disciplinary officer
uh overseeing us in sue robinson who was
agreed upon by the nfl in the nfpa or
does he want to impose the power that
was also agreed upon which still
happened to trump everything i guess the
point in all this is
we act like this new disciplinary
process takes roger goodell out of the
equation
no longer see the judge the jury and the
executioner but really ultimately if the
nfl decides they don't like the
punishment he is still exactly that
i i don't know how they came up with
this agreement that you have an
independent judge
but
and let's take roger goodell's power
away but then if roger goodell wants to
use his power they gave it right back to
him
it makes no sense to me and most notably
it makes no sense that the nflpa would
have agreed to this it's it's silly
literally the last line dan of the the
sections he bet
about this if either appeals is the
commissioner will issue a written
decision that will constitute full fight
and complete disposition of the dispute
so
everything else feels like a dog and
pony show
if the commissioner wants to do
something he can do it have you seen the
ruling
no not yet i've read excerpts that
obviously other people have reported but
i haven't seen the full myself what has
stood out so far
um i think
it was a little predictable to me in
terms of sue robinson essentially saying
that
um
you know nothing he did was proven to be
illegal
but he did you know jeopardize the
personal conduct policy i mean that
that's
i don't know why it's the months to
conclude that like that feels like the
most obvious thing
when you have
um you know this this many women
alleging wrongdoing against we've seen
precedent of other punishments in the
past
come down for
less accusations whether it be
i'm not saying less i'm saying fewer
accusations this is dozens of women
compared to
in the instances of ezekiel elliott and
ben roethlisberger
one allegation
it's not about to me
um
all of this should be viewed in the
scope of
legal findings right while everybody is
making decisions based on legality not
moral compass and you can never convince
me otherwise in this situation
but i also wonder it's about desean
watson but is it about a lot more
because this feels like
precedent long term yeah that's exactly
right
that's and that's what i'm that's
exactly what my point is there
for me when i look at all of this uh
whether it's the nfl the nflpa sue
robinson to sean watson's side this is
not being these decisions are not being
made through a moral lens they're being
made for the purposes of legal
protection and future precedent
i mean
100 percent as much as
there will be outrage based on
uh either side of it whatever was going
to come down
but the
nobody else that's making these
decisions is looking
at it through that lens all they're
looking at it is
whether we want to uh avoid the
courtroom i mean the nfl was willing to
take tom brady to court
over a four-game suspension about
deflating footballs
if they do the same in this situation
but what does that tell you
what do you think the reaction is going
to be i mean i was told this this
morning by a source that the nfl has
pushed for an indefinite suspension they
don't want to appear weak on this
but if the commissioner does an appeal
how does that go
so that's why i feel like all along this
has been a
essentially a pr battle
leading up to this moment it's the same
reason why you saw
six to ten different reporters
the week of the hearing say the nfl
is suggesting a one-year suspension the
nfl wanted everybody to know that they
wanted to go hard on desean watson at
that moment so now sue robinson comes
down with her her ruling and ultimately
we're all left to say well you know the
nfl did want this to be
more than that uh again i think it's
it's
everybody basically
trying to make sure that they come
across
as the public wants them to i that to me
is what's so fascinating about the next
three days
and whether or not
people ends up um being
made by the nfl or the nflpa
uh
they could they could potentially just
make this all go away by everybody just
sitting on their hands and not appealing
jeff thank you i know you got a busy day
we appreciate your time great work on
this uh thank you again thanks dan
that's jeff darlington espn nfl reporter